Lynn had just tried to get a foul call
wasn't close Lakers in great shape
125-117 post game show will have all of
the scenarios he'll have who the Lakers
play
they'll have it for you
crowd rising to their feet next time
they see the Lakers it will be playoff
time LeBron LeBron
put a bow on it he's been feeling it
ever since the game started I mean he is
knocking them down from long range eight
out of 14. you said that somebody needed
eight you didn't say LeBron believe me
today but not LeBron 36 big wins for
LeBron James to go with six rebounds and
six assists in his last two shots have
been from that distance
long long range this one is just a
traditional three that's the first one
this is the last one the last one is way
Deep Way deep look at that
the King has 12 points in the fourth
quarter
eight out of 14 from downtown hit it
while we have a moment here's a word
from Morocco